est-ce que même personne ne pourrait
s'amuser ce soir si vous nous dites d'
accord, donc ce dont je vais
parler avec vous aujourd'hui
est quelque chose dont nous sommes tous conscients et connu
sous le nom de succès,
mais plus important encore, qui définit votre
succès, qu'est-ce qui détermine si ou  pas
tu réussis dans la vie est-ce que ce sont tes
parents tes amis est-ce que tes notes
déterminent le plus ta réussite avec tous les
étudiants ici est-ce le
poste de stage que tu as réussi à obtenir cet
été le travail que tu as d'où tu
viens ta couleur de cheveux ton sexe ou est
voyez vous-même un homme très intéressant
du nom de Bob Procter un ensemble il y a
un seul mouvement mental que vous pouvez faire qui
en une milliseconde résoudra d'énormes
problèmes pour vous cela s'appelle une décision donc
nous pouvons dire que le succès est une
décision miroir loin de ce qui est le meilleur  façon de
déterminer le succès pensez au succès comme à
quelques disciplines simples pratiquées tous les
jours Je suis sûr que les joueurs de
rugby professionnels s'entraînent chaque jour leur régime alimentaire
qu'ils maintiennent t  leur régime alimentaire fait avancer les
étudiants vers leurs examens voyez
voici le grand défi de la vie que vous pouvez
avoir plus que vous n'en avez parce que vous
pouvez devenir plus que ce que vous êtes c'est
le défi et bien sûr l'autre
côté de la médaille se lit à moins que vous ne changiez
comment tu es, tu auras toujours ce que
tu as voir j'ai trouvé pour ma propre
expérience personnelle que le succès ne dépasse pas de
loin votre vision de la vie comment vous
percevez le monde et le
Chernoff à moins que vous ne grandissiez personnellement
là où votre objectif  est que vous vous retrouverez
là où vous êtes la
vie de manières étranges voir avant que j'aie eu
l'occasion de rencontrer mes mentors
comme mr.  Robert Kiyosaki sur m.  bordel
Carson J'avais l'habitude de blâmer les forces extérieures
si je ne réussissais pas dans l'
entreprise que je poursuivais Je blâme
le temps Je blâme l'économie c'est si
difficile d'obtenir un emploi étudiant à cause de l'
état de l'économie
voyez le truc c'est qu'il ne
sert à rien de blâmer ce qui est à l'extérieur
parce qu'ils sont tout ce que nous avons
alors mon mentor m'a donné un conseil
il a vu ma liste de raisons pour lesquelles je n'avais pas
bien fait et je les ai aidés à expliquer
bon sinon tu vas avoir l'air idiot
il a dit qu'il y a un gros problème là
Lester steena tu n'es pas dessus comme
tu vois brillant il a dit que ce n'est pas ce qui
se passe qui détermine la qualité ou la
quantité de ta vie c'est ce que tu fais
qui fait la différence  le Soleil se
lève et puis ce qu'il se couche au
cours des six mille cinq cents dernières années que
nous connaissons d'une histoire enregistrée voyez cela
ne va pas changer le Soleil a brillé sur
nous tous aujourd'hui plus que probablement il
va pleuvoir sur tout de  nous demain voir c'est
ne va pas changer la question que vous
pourriez poser alors comment ma vie
changera-t-elle jamais la réponse quand vous changez alors
que pouvez-vous faire pour mettre en œuvre le changement de vie
je sais qu'il faut beaucoup plus que quelques
jolis mots et phrases la première
étape est la discipline l'auto motivation
vous  sais que je ne sais même pas comment ils
appellent cela l'auto-motivation Je pense que c'est le
seul moyen efficace pour la motivation
si vous attendez que quelqu'un
vienne vous motiver et s'il
ne se présente jamais, vous devez donc avoir une
vie meilleure  planifier que cela découvrir comment les
choses fonctionnent développer un désir pour
quelque chose qui vous intéresse et
découvrir comment cela fonctionne la mise en place si vous
souhaitez réussir étudier le succès les
gens devraient être riches les loups robustes les
gens devraient être heureux étudier le bonheur
ne  Ne laissez pas tout au hasard, saviez-vous
qu'il existe des milliers et des
milliers de livres écrits par des
personnes qui réussissent et qu'ils écrivent exactement
ce qu'ils ont fait pour
réussir et que les gens ne les lisent pas mon
m  Entor m'a également dit qu'il y a deux
façons d'apprendre le numéro un à partir de vos
propres expériences et le numéro deux à partir
des expériences des autres, vous pouvez
économiser beaucoup de temps, d'énergie et de chagrin simplement
en lisant, observez les
gens qui réussissent et voyez ce qu'ils font.  re
faire Napoleon Hill appelle la loi d'
association entourez-vous de personnes
qui ont ce que vous voulez et qui sont
que vous souhaitez ce que vous souhaitez devenir Je
me souviens d'une bonne partie de ma vie je
ne le savais pas et j'étais impliqué dans un
projet de marketing de réseau il y a environ deux
ans et ce n'était pas si réussi
dans le sens où je n'étais pas très doué pour
parler devant les gens si j'étais
offensant, je m'en fichais si je n'avais
aucun sens, je ne l'avais pas  soins j'étais assez
arrogant et puis il y a deux ans j'ai eu
l'occasion de rencontrer mon mentor mr.
Braun al-qasim qui a beaucoup de succès
dans cette industrie et il m'a demandé dans quelle mesure
j'étais disposé à changer un changement d'acceptation
et ce genre de question teste vraiment
le caractère d'une personne plus important encore
si vous agissez ou non sur vos mots si
vous dites oui il  a dit qu'il y avait une
conférence d'affaires en cours à Las
Vegas à l'époque avec des gens comme
Robert Kiyosaki Bob Proctor,
nous allons parler à des gens qui
ont l'expérience et la crédibilité
et il a demandé si j'étais prêt à y aller
inutile de dire  J'y suis allé principalement parce que
je suis très aventureux /
et spontané et je peux dire que
nous pouvons changer toute ma vision de la vie,
cela m'a aidé à changer mon paradigme du
négatif au positif et les gens
que j'ai rencontrés là-bas que j'ai associés  avec
ils m'ont aidé à élever ma conviction et à passer à
l'étape suivante,
également connue sous le nom d'agitation, vous voyez, vous
devez agir sur ce que vous découvrez,
ne laissez pas la connaissance reposer que cela mène
à l'action, mon mentor a également dit que le
être  La première façon d'accomplir quelque chose est d'
écrire des objectifs quotidiens hebdomadaires mensuels des
objectifs annuels écrivez-les c'est la meilleure façon
d'accomplir une action Steve Jobs a dit
que si vous vivez chaque jour comme si c'était
le dernier un jour, vous aurez
certainement raison si vous  regardez le miroir chaque
matin quand vous vous réveillez et dites-
vous que je suis satisfait de ce que je
fais aujourd'hui si aujourd'hui était mon dernier jour sur
terre alors vous pourriez vous demander quel est le meilleur
moment pour agir maintenant dès que
possible c'est  la réponse
ne nous est offerte que quelques opportunités dans
notre vie et ce qui est vraiment drôle à
propos de ces opportunités, c'est qu'elles
se présentent de manière inattendue où vous devez prendre
une décision rapide, la vie est assez brève,
alors vous avez cette incroyable opportunité
d'une vie devant  pour vous, cela ne signifie
absolument rien si vous n'en
profitez pas de son vivant de cette
opportunité maintenant parlons du jour
qui devient une petite amie
aujourd'hui pour moi, c'était quand fin août
matin il y a deux ans quand mon  mentor
m'a appelé et il a dit êtes-vous prêt à
agir sur vos paroles et c'était cette
conférence d'affaires et je devais prendre une
décision rapide et j'avais peur d'
être honnête - et l'inquiétude et la peur
vous submergent si vite que vous ne
Je ne remarque même pas que vous pouvez faire ce que font ces
gens, êtes-vous assez bon,
mais mon désir et mes besoins d'en savoir plus
et de passer de là où je suis actuellement à un
nouvel état m'ont forcé à dire oui deux ans
plus tard, je suis plus confiant et je deviens
impliqué dans des sociétés rencontrant de nouvelles personnes
j'adore me mettre dans des positions
qui me mettent mal
à l'aise
probablement dans
la mauvaise pièce, vous devez être avec des
gens qui sont plus élevés que vous pour
pouvoir grandir là où ils se trouvent en ce
moment maintenant mettons l'âme entre
parenthèses il y a quelque chose de mieux
que la vérité et c'est toute la
vérité bien sûr  assez dès que vous commencez
votre chemin vers la vie changez fixez vos objectifs
il y aura des obstacles qui se présenteront sur
votre chemin qui vont essayer de
vous arrêter je dis que l'
essentiel est de repérer ces obstacles afin
que vous puissiez les surmonter  les émotions les
émotions sont puissantes les êtres humains sont
des créatures émotionnelles et bien sûr les
émotions sont si puissantes qu'elles peuvent
construire ou détruire un individu donc vous devez
non seulement être sage, vous devez être
prudent nous appelons la civilisation la
gestion intelligente des émotions humaines
laissez votre désir pour  ce que vous
voulez dans votre vie
surmonter vos doutes et vos peurs et
maladies d'attitude
ce sont mortels ils peuvent ruiner tout le
travail acharné que vous faites nous allons parler
de quelques-uns d'entre eux le numéro un est la
prudence  t demander la sécurité demander l'
aventure nous sommes ici pour faire une
différence grande ou petite la
vie est un voyage pessimisme le pauvre
pessimiste mène une vie laide comme c'est vrai
et finalement mais celui-ci est mortel
se livrer à celui-ci longtemps en  ough et vous
pouvez être sûr d'obtenir vos futurs conseils
et c'est celui que nous sommes tous coupables de nous
plaindre également connu sous le nom de
cancer économique de l'os se plaindre pendant cinq
minutes et vous en avez perdu cinq tant c'est
grave et enfin essayer et  ne pas
prendre les choses personnelles je sais ce qui arrive
à utiliser sur le plan personnel mais essayez de ne pas le
prendre personnellement je suis sûr que vous pouvez tous
comprendre cela j'en ai eu tellement
dans ma vie où des
expériences personnelles ma vie où j'ai fait  prenez-
les personnellement mais cela ne m'a pas bien profité
il y avait une relation ratée une
amitié un refus d'
un entretien d'embauche un stage un concours
mais Robert Kiyosaki a dit de développer une peau épaisse de
Rhino et de voir chaque rejet comme un
pas de plus vers votre objectif global
maintenant dans  conclusion Je veux dire qu'en
fin de compte c'est à vous de changer
aujourd'hui ou de changer demain ou de changer un
peu ou de ne pas changer maintenant c'est le
moment de choisir mais sachez simplement que votre vie
ne doit plus jamais être la même à partir d'
aujourd'hui  à partir de là uniquement par choix et Henry
Ford a dit que vous pensiez pouvoir
ou non avoir raison, alors cherchez
ces qualités incroyables qui vous composent
en tant qu'individu,
tout le monde a de la grandeur à l'intérieur d'eux,
vous voyez que la grandeur n'est pas ce merveilleux
ésotérique illusoire  fonctionnalité divine que
seuls les plus spéciaux d'entre nous
goûteront, c'est quelque chose qui existe vraiment,
alors placez vos paris
sur combien vous pouvez changer
et sur une note finale, je vous mets au défi de
changer merci
[Applaudissements]